hello movie-going fans my name is ryan
right today I'm going to be covering the
news I found interesting in the second
week of July 2015 a comic con photo of
x-men apocalypse gives us our first look
at apocalypse this comes at perfect
timing because now that gay marriage is
legalized in the United States
Christians everywhere are freaking out
that the apocalypse is actually coming
Marisa Tomei has been set to play Aunt
May in this spider-man reboot this will
be the first on May that i have
previously jerked off to ben affleck is
set to star direct and co-write the next
standalone batman film first the hatred
of being cast as Batman now the pressure
to co-write in direct the next
standalone film this means Ben Affleck
will now fall into a state of panic and
depression resulting in him having to go
to the doctor get a prescription for
viagra to satisfy his unsatisfied wife
Colin Trevorrow the director of Jurassic
world will be directing star wars
episode IX I believe that means nine so
forget about great character is an
emotionally heartbreaking intense story
line because that'll all be sacrificed
at the expense of just having fun blade
may be returning to the big screen with
Wesley Snipes set to revive his role
Wesley Snipes has had a shitty career
for the past few years now so he really
could use the money and I don't mind
donating keep a lookout because in two
weeks the official Deadpool trailer will
be released I recently got a copyright
strike on my channel for doing a
reaction review to the Deadpool leak
test footage so Fox if you're watching
this please remove the strike for it is
[ __ ] with my youtube business all
right guys let's sit for the news of
today if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on all those [ __ ]
social networks Facebook and surround
Twitter vine periscope in you could
catch my videos on Latino Review com
which is run by a man named Calvin who I
think is black actually
it's confusing